I'm Chris Coppola and I'm a scout master with Troop 301 in Ontario, California.
This edition of the Scout Master Podcast is sponsored by Backers Like Me.
And now for you, Scout Master,
Here we are, We're camping, The Scouts are cooking dinner.
One comes across to the campsite, to me with a bowl and a spoon.
He says: here, taste this stew, Tell me what you think.
So I taste the stew and I say: you know, it's not bad.
And he starts walking back to his patrol and I hear him saying:
you know, you guys are such wimps.
I told you that the bugs would just add flavor.
Oh my
Well, this is podcast number 347..
Hey
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green. Let's take a look at the mailbag.
Why not? That's what I always say, Why not?
Let's just take a look.
Well, look, there's mail in there.
And the first message comes from our friend Frank Maynard,
Who is the author behind bobwhiteblathercom.
I will have a link to it in the podcast notes.
Frank got in touch after last week's podcast and said:
I am afraid you muffed another Ohio town pronunciation:
M-E-D-I-N-A is pronounced Medina, not Medina.
Okay, Frank, Thanks Got it.
That's one of my specialities. folks
Send me the name of any town and I will mispronounce it.
But anyway, Frank goes on to say
I enjoyed podcast 346 and your chat with the guys on the trail.
I immediately recognize the name of their newfound hiking buddy Bear,
Eric Hepanomy, And I probably mispronounced that,
But the way that spelled probably gets mispronounced just about all the time,
So let's just call him Eric,
Eric's from the next town over, and his brother, Sam-
I'm assuming it was his brother-
was the Chippewa Lodge, Ottawa chapter chief.
If you talk with Bear again, pass along a virtual left-hand shake
and a WWW from the mighty Ottawa
Will do. Frank,
I did actually get your message over to Bear and he says: hi.
Craig got in touch to say
I can't tell you how much I enjoy Scoutmaster CG.
your podcast program notes the entire experience.
I try to relay every Scoutmaster podcast email
to my Scoutmaster core with a couple of notes from me.
Well, thanks, Craig.
It's always good to know that this is working.
Jeff Bierman got in touch to say: great podcasts
with your former Scouts on the Appalachian Trail.
Their laughs are infectious
and they sound like a couple of good guys to know.
Well, you got that right, Jeff. They really are.
It would be great if you could follow them as long as possible.
I'm going to do my best.
They are really sailing now
and I learned they just crossed the Mason-Dixon line
within the past 24 hours.
They did the- whatever it is- four state challenge.
They're having a great time.
If you keep an eye on the ScoutmasterCGcom Facebook feed
or the Twitter feed,
you'll see every once in a while
we post that we are having a live chat.
These are typically Tuesday mornings at 8 am
Eastern Standard Time
and we'd love to have you come join us.
It's just a group chat for a couple of hours.
You can stop in, say hello,
You can ask questions.
We talk about very serious things
and things that aren't so serious at all.
But this past week
we were joined for the first time
by Travis Anderson, who's a Cubmaster
for PAC-4412
and Assistant Scoutmaster
for Troop 433
in North Dakota.
Adam Roth, who's a Cubmaster for PAC-423,
joined us, as did Ben Long,
who's a Den Leader
and also a new Assistant Scoutmaster
from Rochester, New York.
Tuesday mornings, 8 am
Eastern Standard Time.
Watch the Facebook feed, watch the Twitter feed.
We'll announce the live chat.
Come on over to scoutmastercgcom,
sign in, say hi.
Before we go any further, I want to pause
to thank all the folks who make
this whole thing possible.
There's two ways to do that.
You can become a scoutmastercgcom backer
or you can become a subscriber
through Patreon.
I want to thank Dave Hudson
and Tony Cersei, who added their names
to the list of scoutmasterscgcom
backers since our last podcast,
and thanks to Oz Osbourne-
love the music Oz-
who became a Patreon subscriber
since our last podcast.
This is pretty easy to do.
Go to scoutmastercgcom,
look at the top menu
over to the right. on just about any page
You'll see links that will explain
how to become a backer or how to become a patron.
Well, that's all the standard stuff
that usually happens during this time of the podcast,
And I have some
email questions to answer.
So let's get started. shall we
Send it by name
Email? that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails,
The first email question I have.
the sender is asked to remain anonymous,
but they ask this question.
many past scoutmasters and community members
want to be able to say
they are part of our longstanding troop.
Our membership coordinator
registers them every year,
but some are getting hard to track down
and too old to remember to stay active
on their youth protection training.
We don't really see these people.
it's simply something that they want to stay
associated with the troop.
Is there a way to allow them to say
they are associated with the BSA
without us pulling our hair out every year,
ensuring they have all the paperwork
in order to re-register and keep
their training current?
Maybe they should just register
with the district or the council?
I'm familiar with this.
We had the same kind of thing going on.
We used to keep a couple dozen old
scouts and volunteers on the books
because they wanted to continue
their association with our troop
but with the institution of the
youth protection training requirement
and with the way that training
factors into
the annual journey to excellence evaluations,
the workable. and the BSA
does offer something called
the Scouting Alumni Association
and I'll have a link to that
in the podcast notes
And that seems to answer the need
for people who want to say associated
with scouting and you can even list
the units that you were associated
with and you can
remain a scouting alumni.
So I hope that helps.
Steven Smith got in touch with me.
He's an assistant scout master
and he wrote this:
I'm an Eagle Scout
and assistant scout master
of a troop just celebrating our second year.
We have a relatively small group
of young scouts, the oldest being 14..
Our scouts have come a long way,
but without any older, experienced
scouts it's hard to get them the program
they need. We have a great group
of experienced scouts. We tend
to act as teachers for our scouts.
Lately we've noticed our scouts
have a problem with teamwork. They all try
to give each other orders and little gets done.
You just noticed that lately.
This coming month
we're hoping to give them some kind
of team building game or exercise
each week in the hopes that in them
failing one or two of these exercises,
they'll have a light bulb moment
and realize they have to work better together.
Any ideas on that and how
we can better help them until they become
older, more experienced scouts?
Well, Steve, this sounds like
as ideal a situation you
can be in, as Annie
And I don't really have any advice
for program ideas and I know
that's disappointing to people. sometimes
They want me to tell them like some kind
of key that will unlock the door to,
you know, having older,
experienced scouts or, you know,
keeping scouts interested or something like that.
Well, that key is not
in some kind of magic program
thing that you do. It's not something
that you can present to them. It's not
something that you can do for them.
It's different than that, and so this
is my advice: Stop teaching,
stop doing exercises,
forget everything else
and just do scouting. I think
I want to repeat that: Stop teaching,
stop doing exercises,
stop doing program
and just do scouting. Why do
I say that? Well,
scouting is an iterative
process.
We repeat the same
class of experiences over and over again.
as our scouts go through
them, They gain knowledge. in that knowledge,
romance, growth, and this all
goes in many directions and it's
very deep, but the practice of it
is very, very simple.
Put yourself in your scouts
shoes. Why are they in scouts?
If you ask them
that question, I can just
about 100 percent guarantee
amongst their first answers
will be because it's fun,
and that's the depth of
thought that they've given to the whole thing.
I'm a scout because it's fun.
If you tease that idea out a little bit,
what you'll discover is that the fun part
is going camping and hanging out
with your buddies. So, as I've said
a number of times, boys are
in scouts to go camping with
their friends. That's it. They're not
there to learn anything, They're not there
to do exercises or anything like that.
They think it's fun to go camping with
their friends, hang out with their buddies.
that's why they're there and, happily
enough, Why they're there happens
to coincide with why we're there,
because we're going to make it possible
for them to go camping and hang out
with their buddies. The goal is going camping,
that's all. They aren't there
to learn anything. They aren't there
to do exercises. They aren't there
to do some kind of a
preset program. All we have to do
is make sure that we are
going camping and we're doing it
on a regular schedule, and all
the other things are going to happen.
The cognitive processes
of scouting are going to
happen because we're going camping.
That is the program they need.
Steve, you said we can't give them the
program they need because we don't
have any older scouts. No, I don't
think that's the case at all.
You're giving them the program that
they need by making sure
they get to go camping and
hang out with their buddies. That's
the program they need. We can't
teach them anything. Now, stay with
them. They can't teach them
anything. We can
instruct and we can do
things, but that's not what's teaching
them. Our words and actions
are not what's teaching them.
It's the experiences of
scouting that actually teach
them the things, Not our words
of instruction. I can talk until
I'm blue in the face about how to set
up a tent, but unless you set up a tent,
the only understanding of it is
going to be academic. I can tell you,
I'm going to go camping from A to Z.
I can over, explain
every single thing in an academic
way and you will have an academic
understanding of it, but you'll learn
nothing about it until you actually
do it. Let me go back over that
ground one more time, because
I think it might be a little confusing.
Stop teaching, Stop doing
exercises, Stop presenting a program
and just go camping,
because scouting is an iterative
process. We keep iterating
the same thing again. Hey, let's go camping,
Let's hang out with our buddies.
That's the process that
foments the kind of development,
the development of character, that
we're looking for. Your actions
trying to teach, Your actions
trying to instruct- That's
a fractional part of the learning
process. The experience,
the iteration of experience,
is what really brings results.
So, to go camping and to hang out with your buddies,
you got to know some stuff and, interestingly
enough,
that stuff corresponds to the requirements
needed to advance as a scout. How
about that? So, no matter
what their age. if you
start working with your scouts in the idea
of suggesting that their stuff,
that they need to know to be
able to go camping and hang out with their buddies,
you'll find them working
to figure out what stuff that is.
Do you understand what I'm saying? Rather
than just sitting them down and say, turn to page
46 of your scout handbook,
suggest that the scout handbook
exists and it might have
useful information in it
when you go camping and see what happens.
see if they don't open the book themselves
and start looking around. Be specific:
talk about starting a campfire.
is there any information that
you would need to start a campfire?
where do you think you could find it?
The tough part of this is
that, yes, there is instruction
involved. yes, there is
program involved. There are even
exercises involved. but you
can't build a scouting
on instruction and exercises
and program. Scouting is something
different. Scouting is that
experiential, iterative
process. Now, Steve, you mentioned
that they are giving each other orders
and arguing and each of them
is headed in a different direction
and if that's happening, you can be pretty
certain they are happy boys
doing what boys do, naturally.
Now you can suggest some ideas
about how they could solve some of those
difficulties, but I wouldn't attack them
as difficulties. You can give them
some coaching and the latitude
to do things for themselves.
they will begin to work things out.
Watch them from a respectful distance
and try not to say too much.
Pretend you are driving through
one of those wild animal parks.
keep the windows down and don't get
out of the car. Just watch what happens
and every once in a while
you'll see a chance to share
a useful tidbit of knowledge.
but don't make a habit out of it.
What I like to suggest
is that you just ask questions
that direct them to the discovery
process of finding that knowledge
for themselves. Now, if you take
up this observers post and you watch
carefully, you'll see signs
of leadership and skill and cooperation.
they may be very small,
but you'll see those signs,
that little bit of initiative,
that little bit of skill- that little-
and build on the least little bit of
evidence of what you want to see
grow by mentioning
it in a positive light.
because if you don't talk your head off
and you're not always trying to explain
things or instruct or
put on some kind of a program or do exercises,
when you speak
the scouts will listen to you
and when you mention someone of their
actions directly in a positive
light and you praise them for that,
they are paying very close attention
to that and they will begin
to do the type of things
that earns them that kind of praise
and recognition over and over again
in the same light. don't spend
a whole lot of time talking about things you
don't want to see. so the greatest
skill a scouter can develop, to my
mind, is learning to
ask questions that make
scouts think.
challenge yourself to make as few
declarative statements as possible
and ask as many questions as you like.
get them to discover
what they need to know and how
they ought to act. make them
believe you've forgotten a lot of
things, so they have to find out those
things for themselves. pretend you
don't know anything about advancement
or requirements. pretend they don't
even exist. just go camping
and have fun.
ignore things like organization charts
and job descriptions and value
initiative, cooperation
and leadership. scouting
has an incredibly
powerful natural energy
when you let it do its work.
unfortunately, we've created any number of
organizational assumptions- instructors,
based on the way 50 year old men
think boys ought to
be scouts. but given some latitude,
boys know much better.
they get it right right off the bat.
our job is mostly getting
out of their way and letting them get
with it. they know where you are.
they'll ask questions if they need
help. in the meantime,
you observe, you ask
them questions and enjoy watching
what happens. Steve got back
to me and said that totally helps.
we spend a lot of time camping and I've worked
hard lately at letting the scouts
forget about things. as
a parent, it's hard not to fix things they
forget about and let them fail a little,
but we've been working on it.
at times we really see how these
scouts are going to do great things
when we try to share our love of the
program and spirit and the spirit
of scouting with them. well,
it sounds like you're on
the right path. the final thing I'll
mention on the subject is this:
failure is not failure.
failure is data.
failure is learning. it's a
good thing. it's a process
of self discovery:
how to do things for yourself,
how to learn.
that's the most important part of the
whole thing. that's the real spirit
of what we're after. scouting is
an iterative process.
iterative processes
encounter actions
that are not fruitful.
okay, rather than
saying you know that's a failure, well,
no, that iteration
didn't work, so it's time to move on
to the next one and try again.
George cloud is the scout master
troop 406 in nearby
Royersford, Pennsylvania,
and he got in touch to say this:
I'm meeting with a life scout this afternoon
to review his eagle project
proposal and he hints or tips
on what to look out for.
well, George, the process
of proposing
an eagle project and getting
that proposal approved
is a little confusing
and, I believe
myself, overly complicated.
if you're not familiar with the
process, the first thing to do is
to sit down with the project workbook
and do it thoroughly
and do your best to understand it.
you'll probably make a couple mistakes
the first few times through, but don't worry,
it happens to most of us.
the points I usually find most useful
when I have this kind of discussion with a scout
is to point out
that a proposal is a proposal.
it's not a fully developed plan.
they're seeking approval of an idea,
not necessarily a list of materials.
they should have
an estimated idea of
some materials and things like that,
but they don't need a fully
defined approach yet.
what they want to do is
to get the idea approved.
that's why it's called a proposal.
I counsel my scouts
to imagine they're explaining that proposal
to a young child
and to assume that that child
knows nothing.
so drawings and pictures are always more
effective than words to my mind,
especially when it comes to
this sort of thing.
so the more visual references
they have to explain it,
what their idea is,
I believe the better.
and the other piece of
advice that I usually give
life scouts
working on their ego project proposal
is the difference between a goal
and a plan.
I ask them, when they will be presenting their project
to the troop committee,
when they'll submit it to the district,
to discuss those other things
and
encourage them to think in dates
rather than hazy eventualities,
because frankly,
most of the scouts that I speak with
want to put some of those dates off
as long as possible.
so they just push them into the hazy future
and I encourage them
to try and nail it down to a date.
certain
Steve Cottrell got in touch and said:
I'm curious about the quarterly program.
it sounds like a good idea.
do you still hold an annual program planning conference
with your patrol leaders council?
seems like having the year
outlined is a good idea.
and if they're not setting all of the specific dates,
well, Steve, yes,
we do have an annual planning meeting.
I don't know that I would call it a conference,
but you know, I guess one man's conference
is another man's meeting.
one thing we realized is that we have
four cornerstone events,
and they just happen to
conveniently spread out into the quarters.
in the fall quarter we have
backpacking.
in the winter we have a father and son weekend.
in the spring it's typically a canoe
or a bike trip,
and in the summer, of course, it's summer camp
and our high adventure trips.
and what we really do aim at
in the annual planning meeting
is getting the dates
exact rather than
having the program ideas exact.
we already know what four of the program ideas are,
but getting the dates seems to be
a more important thing.
we look at the calendar. we work around major holidays
and school functions that we know of,
and we aim to have the camping weekends
on the same weekend each month.
this past year it was the third weekend of the month.
this spread the outings and events
apart so that there were
sufficient time to
prepare for them in between.
we managed to do that.
what I've learned over time is that
there is no way
to avoid every single
major or minor
conflict in our calendar.
it seemed to be more valuable to us
to be able to camping weekends
on the same weekend every month,
and that has paid off because
people were more prepared for it.
they didn't have to look at the calendar.
they knew that we were going camping the third weekend
every month. the other note I would give you
is that I have learned not to put a high
premium on scouts coming up with ideas
or worrying about them
repeating ideas that they have enjoyed.
the point is,
as I said earlier, getting out camping
and not much else. that's the point.
we're having an event. we're doing it once a month.
it's camping.
what the theme of that particular
thing is is to me
of secondary importance,
and when it gets really down to where the
rubber meets the road to the scouts,
it's of secondary importance.
we have some idea of what will happen
every month, but the real planning usually
happens two or three months
in advance of that particular trip.
that's where we nail down
more closely the exact
activity that we're going to pursue
while we're out camping.
so that was for pretty quick email questions
this week. I have some more to answer.
next week I would love to answer yours.
you can get in touch with me. it's fairly easy
to do and I'll tell you how to make that happen
in just a moment:
music.
well, thank you for listening to this
347th edition
of the scout master podcast.
here's how to keep in touch.
over at scoutmastercgcom,
there's tons of articles and all the past
editions of the podcast.
so go over and visit in peruse
and, while you're there,
you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog and podcast by email.
join us in the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
over 16,000 folks like scoutmaster blog
on facebook.
we have a whole flock of people
who tweet along with us. on twitter.
we pin Pultritudinous pictures
and proffer them publicly with a parcel
of prolific pinners over at Pinterest.
you can watch us at scoutmastercg
on youtube. but
if you can't face facebook
and twitter makes you bitter and you've no interest
in Pinterest. if you don't put the you,
that's okay.
don't worry about it, old timer.
just zoom in to the late 90s
and send me an email.
you can get in touch with me:
clarkkreen at clark
at scoutmastercgcom.
c-l-a-r-k-e
at
scoutmastercgcom.
if all else fails,
write your question on a piece of paper,
hermetically, seal it in a glass container,
bury that container beneath
a fire pit of any camping area,
and I will be sure to receive
your message, because I have
agents everywhere
by now. it should be abundantly clear:
the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of anyone in particular
other than myself. we are- no, they're
sponsored nor endorsed
by any scouting organization.
that would include the Boy Scouts of America.
no, it is just me with the microphone
and the ability to publish
podcasts online,
and this is how I choose
to lend a hand to my fellow
scouters and have a little bit of fun.
and speaking of fun,
here he is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert, Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone.